[Music]
today we are going to be racing the
subway in new york
the subway means everything to new
yorkers so if someone could outrun it
that'd be quite a feat i remember like
maybe six years ago seeing this video
where
a person with a body cam gets out of the
subway runs to the next stop and gets
onto that same subway
pretty impressive i don't know if it's
real part of today is going to be
finding out if that's actually possible
who is the fastest person in new york
city we came across a person
his name is john diaz hi my name is john
diaz i'm a track star and today i'm
going to attempt to beat the subway
no doubt whatsoever we're going to be
riding the 2-3 train
to chamber street he will exit and then
re-board the train
on park place even though the route we
chose today is pretty short there's a
lot of like twisty turns
stairs i think are going to be a big
problem john looks like he can do it but
when i spoke to him and when we looked
at the course
i saw a little doubt in his face i
believe with the right amount of
training
every person can beat the train it's not
all about physical abilities it's about
the right mindset
jj's gonna have his body cam rolling
from start to finish
so you're gonna know for sure that there
weren't any cuts or editing magic
great how you feeling don't forget about
this
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
john john over here over here john over
here
[Music]
how was that
got a little lost at the end i thought
you were gonna make it
i was like there's no way all right i
just beat the subway
in new york what did i tell you all
right question answered i guess we don't
need a public transit system in the city
anymore
everyone can just run to work as long as
there are showers installed in every
work building i think we have a new city
you